hey this is precious tell Walker and
you're watching mind your decisions this
problem got a ton of responses on
Twitter and I wanted to share it with
you can you solve using only mental math
hat plus hat times pi is equal to 54 pi
times hat plus pi is equal to 50 what is
the value of a hat plus PI plus hat I
saw this in a tweet from Celestia who's
the author of best-selling books
everything I never told you and little
fires everywhere the problem was given
to seven-year-olds as a challenge and it
sparked many arguments because adults
were wondering how a 3rd grader could
solve it the original source of the
problem is Greg Cain you can check out
Greg Tang math com Greg is known as the
math missionary for his work in helping
kids and adults with math since 2001
he's done over 3000 conferences and
events and accumulated over 1 million
frequent flyer miles on 4 different
airlines do check out Greg King math
comm for math books games and other
resources so I thought this was a pretty
challenging problem and I'll ask you can
you solve it using only mental math give
it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so how can we solve this problem well
the first thing that'll make it a little
easier to present will be to substitute
letters for the variables so for the Hat
we'll write the letter H and then for
the pie we'll write the letter P we now
compress our equations and we now have a
standard system of equations so how can
we solve this for H and P well notice
that H P is equal to P H so in the first
equation will change this into a pH now
we have a pH in both of these equations
and if we subtract the second equation
from the first will cancel out the pH
terms so we now have h minus P is equal
to 4 this means H is equal to P plus 4
we now want to go back to one of these
equations so let's look at the second
equation and substitute in for H so we
have P times the quantity P plus 4 plus
P is equal to 50 well we have P plus 4
terms of P and we have one more term of
P so in all we have P plus 5 terms of P
so the equation simplifies to be P times
the quantity P plus 5 is equal to 50 now
we're supposed to be able to solve this
using only mental math so rather than
going to the quadratic formula let's
just think about integer solutions to do
that we'll consider the factors of 50 we
can write that 50 is equal to 1 times 50
or 2 times 25 or 5 times 10 now we're
looking for two factors that have a
difference of 5 because we have P and P
plus 5 and 5 and 10 exactly fit this
characteristic so we can say P is equal
to 5 and therefore we have 5 times the
quantity 5 plus 5 is equal to 50 so
we've solved that P is equal to 5 but
wait we're not done yet because we don't
just want to consider the positive
factors
in this case we could also have two
negative factors being equal to 50 so
could be negative 1 times negative 50
negative 2 times negative 25 and
negative 5 times negative 10 now again
we do have some factors that fit our
characteristic of P and P plus 5 it'll
be negative 5 times negative 10 but in
this case P will be equal to negative 10
and then P plus 5 will be equal to
negative 5 but this will also get us to
50 so we have two possible values of P
we either have P is equal to 5 or P is
equal to negative 10 H is then equal to
P plus 4 so we have H is either equal to
9 or if P is equal to negative 10 H will
be equal to negative 6 we can now solve
for the value of H plus P plus h when P
is 5 and H is 9 we get a value of 23 but
when P is negative 10 and H is equal to
negative 6 we get a value of negative 22
so this is actually a pretty tricky
problem because not only is a tricky to
solve in your head but there are two
possible values for the very last
equation did you figure it out and did
you use only mental math thanks for
watching these math videos which can be
watched for free on YouTube inspire and
build confidence for people around the
world and they already have over 800
million views please subscribe for free
to get the newest videos and email me a
puzzle or math topic presh and mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my merchandise on T spring you
can check out my books which are listed
in the video description and you can
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support